un match pour monter sur le podium
trappes et Suresnes deux équipes du top
5 de régional de s'affronter ce dimanche
12 décembre après un début de match
équilibre et la défense trappiste et
prise de vitesse c'est con c'est
l'ouverture du score locaux n'arrivons
pas à marquer un zéro à la pause ça a
été très compliqué effectivement on
n'est pas rentré dans les meilleures
conditions on a concédé l'ouverture du
score sur une erreur de notre part comme
comme la semaine dernière Alfortville et
ça nous a mis un peu la tête dedans et
après on a été un peu déstabilisé on n'a
pas été complètement
complètement sûr de ce qu'on veut et
voilà malheureusement on rentre au
vestiaire avec le zéro en seconde
période des trappistes monopolise le
ballon il se monte offensif pour revenir
au score ils se font punir sur ce contre
le break est fait pour sur N20 tram le
ce des m'obéissent pas sur cette action
le joueur de sur une touche le ballon de
la main carton rouge et penalty de un
malgré ce dernier coup franc trap ne
reviendra pas au score c'est vrai que on
a on a beaucoup beaucoup de troupes de
justesse technique et et pas forcément
de justesse aussi dans les dans les
choix où on aurait pu faire de
meilleures choses dans un match un peu
compliqué avec une équipe qui est venu
me chercher bien au
après avec le temps un peu difficile de
s'adapter comme on pouvait un peu
compliqué mais on va essayer de se
rattraper
rattraper cette 4e défaite de la saison
et un coup d'arrêt pour les trappistes
dans la quête d'une place dans le haut
du classement des idées noires est 5e
prochain match ce dimanche 19 décembre
sur le terrain de Nanterre un adversaire
direct